Prof: Good morning
everybody.
In the last couple of lectures
we have looked at what happened
when Rome took over
civilizations that were older
than Rome's own,
and arguably even more advanced
than Rome's own.
And what happened,
of course, was an interesting
mix between the architecture and
the architectural forms that the
Romans brought with them,
and what they found in these
highly developed civilizations,
and the interesting mix that
came about because of that.
But we've also taken a look at
what happens when Rome went out
and created cities essentially
from scratch,
built cities where there had
been no cities before.
And what happened as a result
tended to be cities that looked
very much in the Roman stamp.
And we're going to look at a
number of those cities today,
in the western provinces of the
Empire,
in fact, to see what happens
again when Rome builds cities
from scratch in that part of the
world,
and, as I mentioned already,
the distinctive stamp,
this distinctive Roman stamp
that they had.
But at the same time there is
always some impact from the
local civilization,
and to mention in passing that,
at least in the part of the
world that we'll be
concentrating on today,
especially in Gaul,
ancient Gaul,
the Celtic tribes were foremost
there,
and we do see that some of the
impact of those tribes makes
itself felt,
as well as tribes in other
parts of this part of the
ancient Roman world.
Just as a reminder,
I want to show you again a
couple of the monuments that we
looked at last time,
when we were talking about
Greece and about Athens under
the Romans.
And I remind you,
for example on the left-hand
side of the screen,
of this Temple of Olympian
Zeus, the Olympieion in Athens,
which was begun already in the
Archaic period,
the Greek Archaic period,
continued to be built up--
those, the patrons tried to
complete it,
in the course of the
Hellenistic period into the
Augustan period,
and ultimately,
as you'll remember,
it was completed under the
emperor Hadrian.
So a building with a very long
history and a very distinctive
style.
And when it was completed under
Hadrian,
of course, you'll recall that
it looked entirely Greek --
very similar to what it would
have been in the Hellenistic
period.
So those--again,
the Greeks holding very
tenaciously to their own plans,
to their building materials,
and indeed to the kinds of
architects and artisans to carve
them,
that had been carving them for
centuries.
We also took a look at the
building on the right-hand side
of the screen,
which is the Horologion of
Andronicus, or the Tower of the
Winds.
And you'll remember in this
case that the civilization that
had impact on it was another
firmly entrenched civilization
and that is that of Egypt.
We talked about the fact that
while the date of this monument
is controversial--
it might be second century
B.C., it might be Caesarian,
or even into the Augustan
period--it's controversial,
but we talked about the fact
that even though the date is
controversial,
that the monument itself was
built under very strong
influence from Ptolemaic Egypt.
The Ptolemaic Egyptians
particularly intrigued,
for example,
by clocks--this was a water
clock,
as you'll remember--and by
these abstruse,
identifications of abstruse
winds, male winds,
that we see in the uppermost
part.
So again, the impact of two
very high civilizations--
the Greek civilization and the
Egyptian civilization--
on Roman architecture in the
eastern part of the world.
Today we're going to go west,
and we're going to look at
Roman architecture in a variety
of places,
including--and some beautiful
places--
including the south of France:
a series of cities--
and I'll point those out to you
in a moment--
in the north of Italy.
So the north of Italy,
the south of France,
into Spain, into what is now
Spain.
And then also we will dip into
an area called Istria,
which is the uppermost part of
what is now Croatia,
where a place by the name of
Pola is located.
So those western provinces will
be the area that we're going to
concentrate on today.
Now any of you who've traveled
in this part of the world know
that it is extraordinarily
beautiful.
And I show you just one example
of that.
When you go along the French
Riviera,
for example,
you see places as sophisticated
as Monte Carlo,
with its yachts moored here,
and of course with its
glittering nightlife and its
extremely famous casino,
the Casino at Monte Carlo.
There are also other wonderful
cities to visit along here,
modern cities,
such that of Villefranche,
which you see here,
and its fabulous pastel colored
houses,
with boats that are not quite
as magnificent as those at Monte
Carlo,
but nonetheless very
picturesque, a wonderful place
to visit.
So it's not a hardship to have
to travel and look at Roman
antiquities in the south of
France.
I want to begin though with
northern Italy,
with a city in the north of
Italy, a city at a place called
Aosta.
It's the first on your Monument
List for today.
A city that was founded by the
Romans in 24 B.C.,
in the time of Augustus.
And therefore it won't surprise
you to hear that its ancient
Roman name was Augusta
Praetoria: Augusta Praetoria,
the modern city of Aosta.
And it was the last colony that
the Romans founded in Italy;
the last colony.
And it's interesting to see
therefore that this last Roman
colony in Italy takes almost
exactly the shape of the first
Roman colony in Italy.
You'll remember the city of
Ostia, which the Romans founded
in 350 B.C., and the way in
which it conformed to the
typical castrum plan.
We see the same thing here.
We see this typical
castrum plan for Aosta:
a rectangle,
a regular rectangle,
laid out according to Roman
surveying practice.
We see that the two major
streets of the city,
the cardo and the
decumanus,
meet in the center,
and that at that intersection
of those two main streets we see
the location,
as it should be,
of the forum,
most likely.
You'll see a question mark
there, so we're not absolutely
sure, but we think that the
forum was located there.
If you look around at the rest
of the city,
it was very regularly laid out,
with a series of buildings that
we've become accustomed to
seeing in a typical Roman city,
when a typical Roman city is
built from the basics.
You see the baths here.
You see a temple up there,
with a cryptoporticus.
You see a theater and you see
an amphitheater.
This site, by the way,
spectacularly located in the
Italian Alps.
It's at the intersection of two
major trade routes,
in the St.
Bernard passes,
as you can see from this plan
that comes from Ward-Perkins.
And what you can also see,
that's typical of these cities
that the Romans build from
scratch around the western part
of the Empire,
is the fact that the city is
ringed with walls,
and that it has a series of
gates, the openings of which you
can also see in this excellent
plan.
Now I can show you also from
the city of Aosta a surviving
Roman arch,
one of those gateways in fact,
from the city,
that we know dates to the age
of Augustus.
So we give it a date,
the same date,
roughly 24 B.C.
You see it here.
You see, if you remember the
arches that we've discussed from
the Augustan period in the past,
you'll note right off that this
is very consistent with other
Augustan arch design.
By that I mean it has one
single arcuated bay,
in the center,
flanked on either side by
pedestals,
wide pedestals that have a set
of double columns on either
side,
as you can see here.
The major difference between
this and an arch that might have
been put up in Rome at the same
time,
in the Augustan period,
is the fact that it is made out
of local stone,
which is characteristic of so
much of provincial Roman
architecture,
and will be the case for most
of the buildings that we look at
today.
The attic is gone.
There's a modern roof on top of
the structure.
The ancient attic is gone.
But you can imagine that it
would've had a fairly
traditional attic,
with an inscription at the apex
and probably some kind of
sculpture crowning the monument
in antiquity.
Now there's one detail that has
to do with the orders that are
used here that is different from
any other arch that we've seen
before.
And I wonder if any of you
notice what that is.
The columnar orders.
They are what?
Doric, Ionic or Corinthian?
Students:  Corinthian.
Prof: Corinthian.
Okay, everyone agrees they're
Corinthian.
You're absolutely correct.
But what is strange about the
fact--if you look above those
Corinthian columns,
what do you see that doesn't
usually go with Corinthian
columns?
Student:  Oh,
the triglyphs.
Prof: The triglyphs and
the metopes;
the triglyphs and the metopes
that tend to accompany the Doric
order.
So this is very interesting.
We see this mixing of the
orders here, the use of
Corinthian columns but a Doric
frieze with triglyphs and
metopes.
You'd never see that in Rome
itself.
But what it is,
is an interesting playing
around with the canonical orders
that have been passed from Rome
to this part of the world.
This particular architect or
patron,
or the city itself,
whoever was the patron of this
particular monument,
made the decision to go in a
somewhat different route.
So an interesting mixing of the
orders --
an eccentric arch in that
regard, but in every other
conforming quite closely to what
we would see in Rome,
the city of Rome
contemporaneously.
I want to go from Aosta,
in the north of Italy,
to the south of France,
to Provence,
to take a look at the original
town plan of the city of Arles,
the well-known city of Arles.
And those of you who know it,
or have been there,
know it probably primarily as
the city of Vincent van Gogh.
It's in the city of Arles he
spent a good deal of time.
He went to this particular
café so often that it has
borne his name for some time,
the Café
Van Gogh.
And you see another view of a
lovely piazza in the city of--or
plaza in the city of Arles.
And then the famous painting of
Van Gogh,
the panting that he made of
this particular café,
that he used to spend so much
time in,
a café
again, as you see here,
that is still there,
and where you can yourselves go
and sip an aperitif or whatever.
This part, the city of Arles,
a wonderful place to go.
It has a very--I'm not going to
show it to you in any detail,
just a glimpse here of its
famous amphitheater.
It has a very well-preserved
Roman amphitheater.
And the fact that France is so
close--
as you can see in that map I
showed you before--
to Spain, has led to quite a
bit of Spanish influence coming
into this particular part of
France.
And this amphitheater is used
today not only for other kinds
of performances,
but even for bullfights,
as you see.
This is actually a bullfight in
Madrid,
not in Arles,
but nonetheless it's the sort
of thing that has been performed
even in the Amphitheater at
Arles.
Here's the map again.
Before I show you the city plan
of Arles as it would've looked,
I just wanted to remind you of
these towns in relationship to
one another.
So we've come up from Rome.
We've looked at Aosta in the
north of Italy,
in the Alps.
We're making our way now into
the south of France.
And I wanted to point out the
proximity of northern Italy with
the south of France.
Because we do believe that a
lot of the impact of Rome was
felt through the--
on south of France,
or what is now the south of
France--
was passed through the
intermediary of the north of
Italy;
that there were certain kinds
of architectural forms that were
developed in the north of Italy
that were transferred into the
south of France,
because of the proximity of one
to the other.
We're going to be looking at
Arles.
Nîmes.
We're going to look at a
building in La Turbie.
We'll be looking at
Saint-Rémy,
and at Orange,
the great theater at Orange,
as well as a temple at Vienne
-- so all of those sites.
We're going to dip into Spain.
We're going to look at a
famous, famous,
spectacular aqueduct at
Segovia, and a less spectacular
but very well-preserved aqueduct
at Tarragona.
And then we're also going to
make our way,
as I mentioned before,
into Istria,
part of what was formerly
Yugoslavia,
to the site called Pola,
that is now in,
as you know, Croatia.
I want to begin with the city
plan of Arles,
as it would've looked in
ancient times.
And I show you here the city
plan of--
excuse me, not the city plan,
I want to show you the forum,
to give you a sense of what
fora looked like in the western
provinces during this period,
especially in Gaul.
I want to show you the forum
plan of the city of Arles.
And I show it to you here,
with the modern streets
superimposed on top of it.
Because much of it is
underground;
you can't see too much of it
today.
But it has been explored
underground enough where
scholars have been able--
archaeologists have been able
to reconstruct the fact that it
was a large open rectangular
space,
surrounded by columns,
as we have seen is
characteristic of all Roman
forum design,
from the Forum in Pompeii that
we looked at at the very
beginning of this semester.
And although you can't see it
on this particular plan,
there was also a temple on one
short end, as well as a basilica
that was part of this plan.
And I think it's interesting to
think back,
especially as you review from
what we've done from the midterm
through the second midterm,
it's interesting to think about
basilican architecture,
because it was usually a part
of forums,
and when it was a part of--and
in what buildings,
in what fora it was
incorporated:
think back to Pompeii,
think to the Forum of Trajan in
Rome.
But think of the fact that both
the Forums of Julius Caesar and
the Forum of Augustus in Rome
did not have basilicas as part
of them.
Here already in the Augustan
period in--
because that's when this
dates--in the Augustan period we
see a basilica incorporated into
the forum plan,
in what was ancient Gaul.
I mentioned that there's a
well-preserved--there's a
well-preserved
cryptoporticus,
an underground storage area,
around the colonnade.
And you see a view of it here:
extremely well preserved.
And it should remind you of
those cryptoportici that
we looked at very early in the
semester at the sanctuaries that
we explored: the sanctuaries,
you know, at Tivoli and
Hercules Victor;
Hercules Victor at Tivoli and
Jupiter Anxur at Terracina,
for example;
very similar with its
barrel-vaulted corridors.
This one was used for storage
within the forum.
So they would store salt and
fuel and other items that they
would need for daily use.
But it also became
eventually--and you can get an
inkling of that from this view
on the left--
it eventually became a dump for
architectural members that were
no longer needed--
as you can see here,
columns and capitals--
but also for sculpture.
And one of the most famous
portraits of the emperor
Augustus was found in this
cryptoporticus,
dumped there at some later
period, and it's now on display
in the Archaeological Museum in
Arles.
I want to turn now to the
Theater at Orange,
which is one of the most
spectacular monuments that I'm
going to show you today.
And you see it in this
extraordinary view from the air;
a building that you can see
from your Monument List was put
up in the late first century
B.C.,
early first century A.D.,
and it is really something
special,
not only in its own right,
but also because of how well
preserved it is.
And you can see in this view
not only the typical scheme that
we have seen,
we've become accustomed to,
for Roman theater design:
the semicircular orchestra;
the semicircular cavea;
the division into these
wedge-shaped sections or
cunei;
the outer wall of the structure.
And you should be immediately
struck by this outer wall of the
structure,
because the outer wall of the
structure is better preserved
than any other outer wall that
we've seen in the course of this
semester.
It's preserved to its full
height.
It is very severe,
but that severity would have
been lessened in antiquity by
the incorporation of a colonnade
on the front of the structure.
So this very important
building, in that regard,
because we again have this very
well-preserved wall,
which gives us a good sense of
what these walls would've looked
like in antiquity.
And you have to imagine here
again that alleviation of this
severity by that portico.
You can also see here though
something very interesting about
this particular theater that
makes it connected--
although it's Roman in every
way--that connects it also to
earlier Greek theatrical
architecture.
Because you'll remember that
the major difference between
Roman theaters and Greek
theaters was that Romans built
their theaters on their own
hill,
made of concrete,
but the Greeks built their
theaters on actual natural
hillsides.
And if you look very carefully
at this excellent view from the
air,
you will see the way in which
this particular theater,
at Orange, is actually built
into a hillside.
They happened to have a natural
hillside perfect for this kind
of construction,
right where they wanted it to
be.
So they took advantage of that
hillside and they placed--
they supported the cavea
of this structure by that
hillside,
as you can see extremely well.
The interior of the Theater at
Orange is also extremely well
preserved, as you can see here.
You can see the stage.
You can see the semicircular
orchestra.
You can see the stone seats of
the cavea,
and you can also see that the
stage building--
and because the wall,
the outside retaining wall is
so well preserved,
you can also see that the
interior of the wall still
stands, obviously.
And this wall had one giant
niche in the center,
with a projecting element also
in the center,
and then would've had three
tiers of columns,
one on top of one another.
Most of those are unfortunately
no longer there,
but you can see one set of two
pairs here--
the lowest tier with two
columns, the upper tier with two
partial columns above that--
which gives you some sense of
what this would've looked like
in antiquity.
Again we think the tiers,
the columns,
were on three stories.
Remember the date of this,
late-first century B.C.
probably.
And so this does post-date some
of the 60 to 50 to 40 B.C.
paintings that we looked at
that show these kinds of
multi-storied,
scaenae frontes with
columns.
We speculated about the fact
that some of those may have been
based on actual theatrical
architecture,
but that it didn't survive from
that early on,
but it may have been made out
of wood.
But here we see a fairly early
example, in the Augustan period,
in the south of France,
and it is very important in
that regard.
I want to turn from theater
architecture in the western
provinces to temple
architecture.
And just as in Rome,
and just as in every city that
we've looked at,
temple architecture was
extremely important.
The temples that I'm going to
show you--
and I'm going to show you two
of them,
one at Vienne,
in France, and one at
Nîmes,
also in France--are among our
best preserved Roman temples
today.
And it's important to keep in
mind that both of them were part
of complexes.
They stand in isolation today,
but in antiquity they were part
of a complex -- probably some
kind of forum or central space
for that city.
This is the one at Vienne,
which I show to you first,
that dates to,
probably to before A.D.
14.
And it is a temple that was put
up to Augustus and Roma.
It may have been--the
dedication may have been changed
to Augustus and his wife Livia,
at some point;
we're not absolutely sure.
But you see it here in a very
good general view of what it
looks like today.
It's one of these buildings
that has been preserved in large
part because it has been
used--for later purposes.
It was used as a marketplace.
It was used as a museum at one
point.
And that is what has helped to
preserve it.
We see it again here,
and it's interesting,
I think, to compare it to the
restored view of the Temple of
Mars Ultor that was part of the
Forum of Augustus in Rome,
because the dates are roughly
comparable to one another.
And I think that you will see
that it is a typical Roman
temple, in fact,
almost indistinguishable from
what we would see in Rome at the
same time.
So here's an example again of
what happens when you go--
when the Romans go into a part
of the world that isn't already
inhabited by a very highly
developed civilization,
that they make buildings that
look very similar to those that
were put up contemporaneously in
Rome.
The Temple at Vienne is no
exception.
If we look at this temple,
we see it has the typical
Greco-Roman plan with the tall
podium, the deep porch,
the freestanding columns in
that porch.
And we see that the order that
is used here is the Corinthian
order.
Some of the temple is made out
of local limestone.
Some of it is made out of
marble.
But what we see here that's
very interesting
vis-à-vis what was
happening at the same time in
Rome is the cella.
You can see that the cella is
actually very shallow,
much more shallow than the
cella usually is;
and you can see that quite well
in this view over here.
And that same shallow cella we
find at the Temple of Mars Ultor
in Rome.
The other similarity is the
fact that at the Temple of Mars
Ultor in Rome we have
freestanding columns--
columns all the way up to the
back here--
and those columns--and there's
space between those columns and
the wall of the cella.
And that creates a type of
temple design that we refer to
today as a temple with
alae or wings;
wings one on either side of the
cella, formed by that space
between the wall of the cella
and the freestanding columns.
And we see exactly the same
thing over here,
this design of a temple with
alae.
There is no question that this
temple in Vienne was built under
the very strong influence of the
Temple of Mars Ultor in Rome --
all of those features--I mean,
they wouldn't have come upon
those features by accident;
it is clearly being closely
based one on the other.
Here are two more views of the
Temple of Augustus and
Roma/Livia at Vienne,
where we see all of the
features that I've already shown
you,
but where you can see
particularly well the shallow
cella,
the plain--the back wall here
that has pilasters rather than
columns.
And then if you go around the
back you will see it has a plain
flat back, which was the case
also for the Temple of Mars
Ultor in Rome.
A more famous temple,
an even more famous temple,
if that's possible,
an even better preserved
temple,
is the one that you now see on
the left-hand side of the
screen,
which is the famous Maison
Carrée at Nîmes.
It too, it too has been reused
in ancient times as a museum and
the like.
It's still a small museum
today, which is one of the main
reasons that it is so well
preserved.
It is an extraordinary work of
Roman architecture.
I think it's interesting to
compare it to the Temple of
Portunus that we saw much
earlier this semester.
The major difference,
of course, between the two,
the materials that are used.
This is local limestone with
marble.
This--well we won't remind
ourselves, but tufa and
travertine and so on and so
forth, that we looked at
earlier--this is an Ionic
temple;
this is a Corinthian temple.
But once again it seems to be
the Temple of Mars Ultor that
was the main model for the
Maison Carrée or the
Square House at Nîmes.
And I show you another view of
it here.
Because you'll see,
just like the Temple of
Portunus, it has a
pseudo-peripteral colonnade,
and you can see that extremely
well.
Yes, the columns encircle the
entire monument,
including the back wall,
but those columns are engaged
or attached to the wall going
all the way around.
Here you can again see the
opus quadratum blocks of
this local limestone that's used
for the walls,
and then marble used for the
columns and also for the
capitals of this glorious and
very well- preserved Roman
temple.
And here some spectacular
details of the capitals of the
Maison Carrée at
Nîmes,
and the frieze,
and also the decoration up
above.
And what's interesting about
these capitals,
if you look at them in detail
you will see that not only are
they Corinthian,
and we can see the spiral
volutes growing out of the
acanthus leaves down below,
but if you compare these
capitals to a capital,
a preserved capital from the
Temple of Mars Ultor in Rome,
you will see that not only are
these based on these,
but that they are so close,
so close,
that there is absolutely no
question,
I believe--well this was not
suggested by me but by a scholar
who studied these in great
detail and determined and
suggested,
and all of us have believed it
ever since--
that these are not only based
on those,
but that the same workshop
worked these capitals for the
Maison Carrée as for the
Temple of Mars Ultor in Rome.
Now that works well
chronologically,
because you'll remember that
the Temple of Mars Ultor in Rome
was dedicated in 2 B.C.
This building,
as you can see from your
Monument List,
was built in around A.D.
5.
So there was perfect--it was
perfect timing for those
architects and artisans who had
been successful at the Temple of
Mars Ultor in Rome,
this major commission,
allowed themselves,
we believe, to be hired out to
those in the south of France,
to make the trip to Nîmes
in order to build a temple in
the model of the Temple of Mars
Ultor in Rome,
at Nîmes;
the result, the Maison
Carrée.
So this is--I've made this
point in other lectures about
the fact that there are certain
times when we can document not
only the exchange of
architectural ideas but even the
exchange of architects and
artisans,
going from one part of the
Roman world to another,
in search of commissions.
And this is one of those times
where we can document with
certainty that artists working
in the employ of the emperor
himself,
Augustus, made their way to the
south of France to create this
amazing temple from scratch.
Once again, a temple very much
in the model of the most famous
temple of its day in Rome,
and that is the Temple of Mars
Ultor,
in the Forum of Augustus.
One more detail.
Here's the Mars Ultor capital
again, and over here the
capitals of the Maison
Carrée.
And I show you above the
frieze, which is extremely well
preserved,
and you see this flowering
acanthus plant,
that should immediately remind
you of contemporary decoration
in Rome;
think of the flowering acanthus
plants of the Ara Pacis
Augustae.
So once again proof that there
is a very close connection to
what's going on in Rome at this
time, and in the south of
France.
Here's another spectacular view
of the Maison Carrée,
as it looks in its location
today.
In the center of a plaza,
surrounded by the daily life of
Nîmes, as you can see so
well here -- still very much a
part of daily life.
And very interesting is the
fact that if you look across the
street,
from the Maison Carrée,
you see a building that was
designed by the very famous and
very talented British architect,
Norman Foster.
It's also a museum,
and it's a play on the name of
the Maison Carrée,
it's called the Carrée
d'Art.
It's a museum that has modern
art, and it mostly exhibits its
permanent collections.
But you can see--and I'm going
to show you a detail in a moment
to bring this point home--
you can see that Norman Foster
has really looked at,
and studied,
the Maison Carrée,
and has created a modern
version, a very modern version
of the Maison Carrée.
If you look at the Maison
Carrée and its deep porch
and its high podium and its
single staircase,
this façade orientation,
all the usual Roman elements,
and look at this building,
you will see that he too has
created a kind of portico in the
front.
They're not actual columns,
they're piers,
but piers--and very slender and
elegant piers--
but piers nonetheless that are
clearly being played off the
columns of the Maison
Carrée.
And look at the way in which he
has done the glass exterior.
He has divided it into a series
of panels that are clearly,
I believe, reflecting--and I'm
sure he knew he was doing this
at the time--
clearly reflecting the panels
of the ashlar masonry of the
walls of the actual Maison
Carrée.
So this is very interesting.
We see not only dialogue
happening,
you know, within Roman
buildings themselves,
in Rome itself and in various
parts of the world,
but this ongoing dialogue
between ancient monuments and
modern buildings in cities like
Rome--
the Ara Pacis in the Meier
building is one example--
but also in some of these other
cities,
like Nîmes in the south
of France.
And, by the way,
you can go up -- there's a roof
garden that you can go up to,
on the top of this,
of the Carrée d'Art,
in order to see a spectacular
view from above of the Maison
Carrée.
Now one of the most important
elements of the Romanization of
the Empire was the fact that as
the Romans went in and built
these new cities,
in East and also in West,
they supplied it with amenities
that weren't there before.
And this was especially
important in the western
provinces where again the
civilization had not been all
that high, prior to this period.
So the Romans come in and they
build aqueducts with a vengeance
in the western provinces,
in the south of France,
in Spain, in order to provide
these towns with a water supply.
And I want to show you a couple
of examples of our best
preserved and most spectacular
Roman aqueducts anywhere in what
was the ancient Roman Empire.
I want to begin with perhaps
the--with certainly the most
famous of these,
the so-called Pont du Gard,
also at Nîmes.
And I show you first a map,
which gives you a sense of what
was going on here.
The patron, by the way,
of the Pont du Gard at
Nîmes was none other than
Marcus Agrippa:
Marcus Agrippa whom we've
talked about several times this
semester,
the close friend,
confidant, right-hand man,
son-in-law, hoped-for heir of
Augustus,
who we saw was building
buildings in Rome.
He built the baths that bear
his name,
the Baths of Agrippa,
and he also built that first
Pantheon,
that first temple to all the
gods, with its caryatid porch.
We saw that he was active as a
builder in Athens,
where he built the Odeon of
Agrippa,
and where he was honored with a
statue on top of a pier on the
Acropolis in Athens.
He also was active in the south
of France as a great builder,
and it was here that he was
responsible for commissioning an
aqueduct that would bring water
from thirty-one miles away,
up in the mountains,
down to the city of
Nîmes.
And this map gives you a very
good sense of exactly how that
was done.
The source was up there,
at the top, the top pink circle
up here, made its way all the
way down to the city of
Nîmes here.
Now the Romans were very clever
about how they built aqueducts.
They let gravity and the change
in terrain essentially do the
work for them.
They placed terracotta pipes
underground,
for the most part,
on sloping ground,
and allowed the water to come
from the hillsides or the
mountains down into the city,
just as they did here.
On occasion they allowed those
terracotta tubes to be carried
by low walls.
But sometimes they got to a
point where they had to cross a
body of water,
and that is exactly what
happened here.
The River Gard of the city of
Nîmes,
of the area of Nîmes,
goes through--is located at
this particular point,
and so the aqueduct system had
to cross the river.
How did they do that?
They couldn't tunnel it
underground, they couldn't place
it on a low wall,
so what they did was build a
bridge;
they built a bridge to carry
that water across the body of
water.
And the result of that is what
you see here.
This is the famous Pont du Gard
at Nîmes.
This is the bridge that serves
to carry the water across.
They place the terracotta pipes
in the aqueduct itself,
and that water is carried
across that aqueduct.
Now what's particularly
extraordinary about this
monument,
besides that feat of taking
that water across the river,
is the fact that it is--well if
you look at the building
technique,
you can tell that it is made of
ashlar masonry;
ashlar masonry that is local
stone,
in this particular case,
as we have seen is the case,
for the most part,
in architecture in the south of
France,
in the Roman period.
But what is amazing about this
particular aqueduct,
besides this great engineering
feat,
is the fact that the architects
have paid enormous attention to
the exact measurements,
not only of the arch itself,
but of the arcuations.
And they have worked up all
kinds of elaborate mathematical
theorems in order to get to the
point where they play these
shapes,
and the sizes of these shapes,
well off against one another.
The larger arcuations below are
perfectly mathematically worked
out, so that they work well with
the smaller ones up above.
And we see in a building like
this,
I think, something that is
really impressive:
not only a sign of
Romanization--
I mean this is--when you talk
about Roman imperialism and the
Romans taking over the world in
ancient Roman times,
one could think about that,
in part,
in a negative way.
I mean, imperialism and taking
over and creating an empire can
be viewed negatively.
But one of the positive things
that the Romans brought,
one of the many positive things
that the Romans brought to these
under-developed parts of the
world,
was what we call Romanization;
bringing these amenities,
bringing things like water to a
city, so that it could live at a
higher level than it was able to
live before.
But besides that,
when you look at an aqueduct
like the Pont du Gard at
Nîmes,
I think you'll agree that
although we would call this a
feat of Roman engineering,
first and foremost,
the Romans have been adept
enough,
both through paying attention
to these mathematical
considerations,
but also to carving the stone,
to making the stone really work
aesthetically,
that they have essentially,
in this aqueduct,
transformed engineering into
architecture,
into what we would define as
architecture.
I want to show you two other
aqueducts.
The first--both of them in
Spain--the first at Tarragona
and the other one at Segovia.
First a reminder of the fact
that Spain, as you'll recall,
was extremely important in the
Roman period because two of
Rome's emperors came from Spain;
think of Trajan,
who was born in Spain,
and also Hadrian,
whom we see here on the left.
A map of Spain showing the
locations of Italica,
where Hadrian was born,
but also the two sites that
we're going to look at,
Tarragona, Tárraco,
which was located very close to
Barcelona,
near the sea,
as you can see here,
and then further inland
Segovia;
Segovia which is near Madrid,
the city of Madrid.
So very accessible;
for any of you traveling Spain,
these are sites that are
extremely accessible,
and especially Segovia,
well worth looking at.
I just want to show you the
aqueduct at Tarragona briefly.
You can see it here on the
screen, an aqueduct that dates
to the Augustan period.
And it's a handsome work of
architecture.
It has ashlar blocks,
as you can see:
local stone.
But it doesn't have the finesse.
I think you can see here now
how great the Pont du Gard is,
because it doesn't--it's
attractive,
it does the job,
it's a great engineering feat--
but it doesn't have the
aesthetic values that the Pont
du Gard does,
with its arches that are the
same size,
on the lower story,
and then in the upper story it
doesn't have the appeal
aesthetically,
visually, that the Pont du Gard
does;
but it does its job.
However, the aqueduct at
Segovia is quite another story.
The aqueduct at Segovia is
right up there with the Pont du
Gard at Nîmes as one of
the great works of Roman
engineering and of Roman
architecture.
And what makes it all the more
spectacular is how much of it is
preserved.
And I think you can see that
extremely well here,
in this amazing view of the
aqueduct marching--
making its way across the
center of the city of modern
Segovia,
in this truly spectacular image.
As you can see from your
Monument List,
the date of the aqueduct at
Segovia is very controversial.
There are some people who think
it's first century;
there's some people who think
it's second century.
I think it is most likely to be
second century,
and probably put up during the
time of Trajan,
the emperor Trajan.
But we're not sure about that.
Whenever it was put up,
it is an incredible example of
aqueduct engineering and
aqueduct architecture.
And it does allow us to see a
couple of things that we--it's
very distinctive in its own
right;
it's beautiful,
but beautiful in a very
different way,
as we see from the Pont du
Gard.
But it does allow us to look at
a couple of other features of
Roman aqueduct planning and
design that I think are worth
talking about.
I show you here another view of
the aqueduct at Segovia,
and you see here that it is for
the most part a two-tiered
aqueduct system.
But what they've done here to
vary it,
and to make it much more
interesting aesthetically than
the aqueduct at Tarragona,
is to make those two stories
different in height.
So the lower story is much
higher, as you can see,
with much more attenuated
arches;
and then the upper tier is
lower, with much smaller arches.
The other thing that they've
done -- using local stone --
they have left the stone in a
somewhat rougher state.
It isn't quite as rough,
perhaps, as Claudius'
buildings--
but left in a fairly rough
state, which gives it a real
sense,
as you look at it,
of the texture of that stone,
of the materiality of that
stone, in a way that makes this
particular building extremely
attractive and impressive.
And you can see here--this view
is also very helpful because you
can see people standing below
which gives you some sense of
the very large scale of this
particular aqueduct.
Here's another view.
This is one of my favorite
views of the aqueduct at
Segovia,
because I think here you can
really get a sense of the
coloration of the stone,
of the texture of this slightly
rough stone,
and of the way,
even in the architecture of
aqueducts--
again mainly,
an aqueduct is built mainly for
a practical purpose,
to bring water from one
part--one place to another
place,
to provide an amenity,
as we've talked about it,
a significant and important
day-to-day amenity.
But even with that,
even though it is essentially a
practical building,
aesthetics are never far from
the Romans' minds.
And when this particular
aqueduct was designed,
not only did the designer have
in mind the texture of the stone
and the way in which the light
of Spain,
this particular part of Spain,
hits that stone at any given
time of day,
but the whole concept of vista
again.
When you wander along this
particular aqueduct--because it
goes on for quite awhile;
you can do that,
and you're not on top of a body
of water as well.
So you can walk along it down
below and see what you see as
you meander through it.
And it is amazing aesthetically
again how they have set up a
series of views and vistas,
from one part of this aqueduct
to another.
As you stand here and you look
at it,
making its way,
almost marching its way--
in fact, I like to think it's
Trajanic because it's almost
like Trajan's army marching
through the city of Segovia,
off to some military exploit in
the far reaches,
because--the way it marches
through the city,
as you can see here.
But all of these wonderful
views and vistas and panoramas
that one can see,
depending upon where one stands
in the city,
where one stands beneath the
arches themselves,
is really spectacular,
and clearly was very much in
the minds of the architect who
designed this.
Here's another very good view
where if you stand below the
aqueduct and look up,
this is the sort of view that
you see,
with the rough stones,
even in the vaults of the
arches themselves:
an incredible work.
And again, the fact that it is
as well preserved as it is,
is really something to be
grateful for.
Here's a very interesting view,
because it also shows you what
happens with aqueduct design
when the terrain changes.
So in the center of the
city--in the views that we
looked at just before--
they were able to build,
the ground level was low
enough,
that they were able to build
the aqueduct in two stories,
with that very high first story
and then the lower second story.
But what happens when the
terrain shifts,
when you go--because again
they're taking advantage of a
source that is located higher
up,
with the hope that gravity will
do the work for them and allow
that water to flow from that
source,
down into the city.
And that is exactly what they
did here.
The source is farther away and
it's high.
So the water has to be piped
into this structure and make its
way down from the hillside to
the city.
So you see the ground rising
here, to go up that hill.
And what happens is that they
have to adjust the aqueduct
according to the changing
terrain.
So if you look at this
particular section,
you will see that the bottom
story is just an arch.
The arch rests on the ground,
so that they--because it has to
be much shorter at this juncture
than anywhere else.
And you see the same--well you
see it changing somewhat here,
as it makes its way.
But you see it rounding the
corner,
and the way they have had to
make these adjustments,
and made them so well,
without losing the impressive
aesthetic quality of this
particular structure.
Once again, a tribute to the
fact that these Roman architects
were not only great engineers
but also, without any question,
world-class architects.
There's an interesting monument
that is located--
you can see the aqueduct of
Segovia in the back left there--
there's an interesting monument
that was put up to celebrate the
bi-millennium of the aqueduct in
Segovia.
And it's interesting to see
what they put at the top:
the she-wolf suckling Romulus
and Remus to underscore the
close connections between
ancient Roman Segovia and Rome.
Another very interesting
building in France is the one
that I show you now,
which was a fountain.
These aqueducts brought not
only water for daily use but fed
fountains.
And I want to show you one
fountain from Roman Gaul,
from what is France today,
the so-called Temple of Diana.
It wasn't a temple,
it was a fountain,
as I mentioned,
and it was built during the
Hadrianic period,
between 100 and 130.
What makes this fountain
particularly interesting is if
we just looked at this--
if I asked you,
if I put this up and said to
you: "What do you think
this was?"
you would be unlikely to say a
fountain;
because you can see that this
structure is in the form of a
basilica.
It's a barrel-vaulted central
chamber, with side aisles that
are also barrel-vaulted.
You can see the barrel vault of
this side aisle over here.
You can see a barrel vault of
the central space here.
You can see that there are
columns on tall bases.
You can make out,
over here, a triangular
pediment on top of a niche.
There were a series of niches
along the wall,
with alternating triangular and
segmental pediments.
But most interesting of all is
the central space,
the central barrel-vaulted
space, with these barrel-vaulted
side aisles,
which is exactly the scheme of
a typical basilica.
And it's another example of
something I've shown you
throughout the semester,
that I've called the
interchangeability of form;
the way in which certain
building types,
in this case a basilica,
built initially as a civic
structure for the trying of law
cases,
becomes a plan that is used in
other contexts;
whether it's in residential
architecture,
as we've already seen,
and in this case in the form of
a fountain.
So that's particularly
interesting.
Also interesting is the fact
that although this is a
barrel-vaulted structure,
it is made entirely out of
local stone --
no concrete whatsoever in this
particular part of France.
No concrete, stone construction.
It's a masterwork when you
consider that this was all done
out of stone,
and done extremely well.
Look how smooth the stones are.
And look, the designers have
even been talented enough to
create ribs, with stone,
in that stone barrel vault,
for this amazing structure.
And you should be reminded,
when I talk about the
interchangeability of form,
of the underground basilica
that we looked at way back when,
in the time of Claudius,
which was built underground,
made out of concrete,
faced with stucco,
as you'll recall,
but used for a secret sect,
and in this case the use of
this basilican structure for a
fountain in Roman France.
Up to this point we have looked
at monuments that were made
possible by Rome's subjugation
of this particular part of the
world;
the subjugation we know of at
least forty-four Alpine tribes.
And so while all of these
buildings that I've shown you
come because of that subjugation
and subsequent Romanization of
the area,
there is one monument,
spectacularly sited,
that actually celebrates,
honors, that very subjugation,
and it's to that that I now
want to turn.
It is, as I mentioned
spectacularly sited,
along the French Riviera,
not far from Nice,
not far from Monte Carlo.
You see it here.
It is the Trophy of Augustus,
the Tropaeum Augusti,
as you'll see on your Monument
List,
that is located in a town
called La Turbie and you can see
it rising up in the midst of
modern La Turbie here.
It dates, we believe,
to 7 to 6 B.C.,
and thus in the age of
Augustus, and celebrates,
quite specifically,
Augustus'--and the inscription
tells us this--
Augustus' subjugation of
forty-four Alpine tribes in this
particular part of the world:
a monument put up to honor that
victory of Augustus.
So essentially a trophy
monument.
You can see that it is only
partially preserved.
And I show you here a view of
it down the street,
the modern street,
as it looks today,
where you can see it rising up
over that street.
And if you look very carefully,
you will see that the stone
that the structure is made out
of is very similar--
in fact exactly the same--as
the stone used for the local
houses.
Now this is very interesting,
because what--
the monument did not look--even
though it's only partially
preserved today,
even less of it was preserved
earlier on,
and it was in the 1930s that an
American patron decided that he
wanted to reconstruct,
as best that could be done,
the Trophy Monument at La
Turbie.
Because there was recognition
that the monument at La Turbie
had served as a quarry,
essentially for the local
inhabitants,
and that over the years they
had been taking the stone from
the Victory Monument of
Augustus,
and using it--that's why it's
the same stone--
using it in their houses.
And this American wanted to
rectify it,
so he donated the funds that
enabled them to tear down,
to demolish,
thirty-two houses,
and come up with 3000 fragments
from the Victory Monument,
the trophy at La Turbie,
and reconstruct it as best as
they could from those fragments.
And that's what you see there
now.
Here's a view of it as it looks
today, as well as a model.
And what you can see from both
of these is not only the
inscription and the trophy in
relief,
on this side,
that mentions the forty-four
Alpine tribes,
but the monument itself.
And this model makes it very
clear what the general form was:
a round structure,
with columns encircling it,
on a base,
and then the whole thing placed
on a very large--
a tall pedestal,
with a pyramidal element at the
top,
and a crowing statue at the
very apex.
This scheme of placing a
rotunda on top of a tall base is
something that we have seen as
characteristic of funerary
architecture,
from the age of Augustus.
Think of the Tomb of Caecilia
Metella, for example.
And it is that scheme that is
used here.
So another example of this
interchangeability of form --
that a form that was used for
mausoleum architecture now used
for a trophy monument,
of the same time,
but in a different part of the
world.
The model also shows you that
there were niches around the
central circular structure.
Those had in them portraits of
Augustus' lieutenants,
who helped him placate this
particular part of the world.
And then at the top of the
stepped pyramidal structure,
a portrait, a bronze statue of
the emperor Augustus himself.
Here's a detail of the Victory
Monument at La Turbie,
with all of those stones from
those thirty-two demolished
houses reused here to
reconstruct it.
There is concrete used here,
but it's a Gallo-Roman form of
concrete.
You'll see in Ward-Perkins that
he refers to this work as
petit appareil,
p-e-t-i-t a-p-p-a-r-e-i-l,
which is essentially a
Gallo-Roman version of concrete
construction,
with stone facing,
little work,
little pieces of stone,
that are very similar to
opus incertum,
but different enough and
distinctively French enough to
be called petit appareil.
The victories,
Augustus' victories and
pacification of this part of the
world also led to the
construction of arches.
And I want to turn to a couple
of those now.
The Arch at St.
Rêmy, also in the south
of France.
You see it here.
It dates to around 20 B.C.,
and it probably served as both
an arch in honor of these
victories that Augustus
celebrated here,
but also as a gateway into the
city.
It's very simple.
It looks very much like we've
come to know Augustan arches
are,
with a single arcuated bay in
the center,
columns, in this case,
on two separate bases,
fluted columns.
The capitals are not preserved,
so we don't know if they were
Corinthian, but they were
probably Corinthian.
A very elaborate archivolt,
as you can see here,
with the coffering extremely
well preserved.
And then if you look very
closely at the decoration,
you see a couple of figures
standing on either side.
These are actually--they're
headless now--but they're
actually figures of captives;
of captives,
of local captives,
to make reference again to the
fact that this was military,
a military operation,
that allowed Augustus to take
over,
to subjugate these forty-four
Alpine tribes,
and others in this particular
area,
and that that subjugation is
referred to here by the
representation of those captured
barbarians.
A much more important and more
interesting arch is this one.
It's an arch that is located in
Orange--back to Orange--also in
the south of France.
The date of this monument is
very controversial,
and I think by looking at the
general view,
and also a detail,
you can see why.
It is a triple-bayed arch,
with a large central arch,
two smaller ones on either
side, with columns on tall
bases, Corinthian columns in
between them.
You can see that the central
element, with its pediment,
projects into the viewer's
space.
You can also see that every
inch of space is completely
covered with decoration--
figural decoration,
piles of arms and armor from
the enemy--
so much so that it tends to
dematerialize the arch.
These are all characteristics
of later Roman architecture--
think the Arch of Septimius
Severus,
which I'll show you again in a
moment--
which has led some scholars to
date this as late as A.D.
200 or A.D.
203,204, at the same time as
the Arch of Septimius Severus.
And it was long thought to be
that also because no one could
concede that this idea of the
triple-bayed arch could turn up
in let's say Augustan or
Tiberian France,
Gaul, before it turned up in
Rome.
So getting back to that issue
I've raised on several occasions
about center and periphery.
Does everything flow from the
center,
or are forms sometimes
developed in the periphery and
then make their way back into
the center,
is an age-old and very
interesting question to ask.
But I think you can see the
reasons why scholars,
some scholars,
have dated this to the Severan
period.
Here's a view--and I'll say
more about that in a moment--
a view here,
another view showing an
engraving,
giving you a sense of the kind
of sculptural decoration that
would've been placed at the top:
the omnipresent figure in the
chariot,
four-horse, or in the
case--four-horse,
I think, in this case, chariot.
And then figures of captured
barbarians, as well as trophies
on the apex.
Here's our comparison with the
Arch of Septimius Severus in the
Roman Forum.
And I think you can see the
close association between the
two: the triple bay,
the profusion of decoration
that we see in the arch on the
left-hand side as well.
Here's a detail of the attic,
which shows you an interesting
battle scene where the figures
are very heavily outlined,
as you can see here,
which is unusual.
Scholars have suggested,
and I think correctly,
that the reason for that is
that these artists,
in this part of Gaul,
were probably working from copy
books,
or copy scrolls I guess I
should say: drawings of battle
scenes,
typical Greco-Roman battle
scenes, that they could use--
Hellenistic battle scenes
perhaps, or early Roman battle
scenes-- that they copied.
And these were drawings,
and consequently they copied
them quite exactly,
by showing the outlines around
the figures.
It's a speculation,
but I think it's an interesting
speculation, in this very
frenzied battle scene from the
uppermost part.
With regard to the date of this
monument though,
the plot thickens.
Oh, one other detail.
If you look at the side of the
arch, you see an arcuated
element inside.
You can barely see the
triangular pediment,
but there's an arcuation inside
an unbroken, a complete
triangular pediment.
So that scheme of placing the
arcuation also tends to be a
late feature.
However, scholars who've spent
a lot of time looking at the
sculptural decoration of this
monument,
at the piles of arms and armor
that one finds there--
which, by the way,
includes piles of arms and
armor from a naval victory,
which is interesting,
as well as piles of arms and
armor from victories on land,
which has made some scholars
speculate that this refers to a
kind of generic victory,
to victory on land and sea,
by whomever this honored.
But very interesting is the
fact that there is one armament
that is inscribed with the name
Sacrovir, S-a-c-r-o-v-i-r,
Sacrovir.
Sacrovir we know was someone
who was living and active in the
time of Tiberius.
He led a revolt in this part of
Gaul, in A.D.
21, against the local Roman
governor and his excessive
taxes.
And it has been speculated that
that Sacrovir,
who is mentioned here,
is that very same Sacrovir,
and that it is very conceivable
therefore that this arch was put
up in the time of Tiberius.
I've given you a date of A.D.
25.
I believe that myself,
although it does defy
imagination,
to a certain extent,
to think of an arch,
with all of these features that
I've described today,
as early in the south of France
as A.D.
25.
But it's something for you to
think about in terms of our
whole question of the
relationship between center and
periphery.
I want to show you the last
group relatively quickly,
just to dip into Istria,
as I said I would,
to the uppermost part of what
is today Croatia,
to look at one more arch,
in a different part of the
Roman world,
but during the same period,
the end of the first century
B.C., an arch at Pola.
I show you the location here of
Pola,
or Pula, at the very uppermost
part of Croatia,
very close, exactly at,
I mean it's just--
when I went there once,
you literally,
you go across the border and
there you are,
the Italian border,
you're in Pola.
And you see the rest of Croatia
here,
with the other great site of
Split,
which we'll look at next time,
and of course the famous city
of Dubrovnik at the base.
You see the arch extremely well
preserved.
Another typical Augustan arch:
single bayed,
two columns,
Corinthian order,
on a shared base.
If you look at the attic,
the attic is interesting.
Local stone once again.
Look at the attic,
you'll see bases that are
inscribed at the top,
and those bases are very
helpful in terms of telling us
something quite extraordinary,
and that is that this arch was
put up by a woman.
We know her name:
Salvia Postuma,
Sa-l-v-i-a P-o-s-t-u-m-a.
who put this monument up to
three male members of her
family,
who were involved in military
operations at this particular
time,
died, and then were honored by
this monument.
I show you a reconstruction of
what the uppermost part probably
looked like when there were
statues of those three male
members of the family,
possibly in their military
costumes,
although we don't know for
sure, at the apex of the
structure.
Here's a detail of it also over
here, where you see victories in
the spandrels;
you see the Corinthian capitals;
you see cupids carrying
garlands;
all the kind of decoration.
You see some acanthus leaves,
very much like those in the Ara
Pacis: all the kinds of
decoration that have been
transported from Rome to be
used,
in this case,
in the north of former
Yugoslavia for this arch.
We see the Corinthian capitals
here.
We see the victories here.
We see the cupids with the
garlands over there.
We see a chariot scene here.
The chariot scene is an
interesting reference to the
race of life,
a reference to victory in
athletic competition,
as well as victory over--you
see the bucrania there
also;
clearly another touch of Rome,
of the Ara Pacis.
But this interesting--we've
seen this throughout the
semester,
the close correlation in the
minds of the Romans between
victory in battle,
victory in athletic
competition, victory in the
hunt,
and also victory over death.
And all of that comes together
well in the arch here.
If you look up into the vault,
it's very well preserved.
In the center a representation
of an eagle, with a serpent,
holding a serpent;
this is probably a reference to
death and rebirth.
And remember,
this is Augustan in date,
so it predates the vault of the
Arch of Titus in Rome.
But this whole idea of placing
in the vault a scene of death
and rebirth, leads ultimately,
I think, to that divinization
scene of Titus.
I want to take you very quickly
to show you an important tower
tomb in the city of St.
Rêmy--we're back in the
south of France--St.
Rêmy, the ancient Glanum,
G-l-a-n-u-m;
ancient Glanum,
which was a very highly
developed town,
also in the Greek period.
So here we see some overlay.
We have local Celtic custom.
The Greeks infiltrated here,
then the Romans;
all of that piled one on top of
another, to make a very
distinctive city.
You can also see from the
remains, there are extensive
remains at Glanum,
more than most of these ancient
French towns,
where you can see baths and
temples and parts of houses and
peristyles and so on,
quite well preserved.
I show you here,
for example,
some honorific bases and
altars.
And over here a hypocaust from
one of the baths,
looking very much like a
hypocaust we would see in
Pompeii of like date.
I also want to mention,
in case any of you are making
your way to the south of France
anytime soon,
it is located,
the city of Glanum,
located very close to the
wonderful town of Les Baux;
in fact, Glanum is in the
shadow of Les Baux,
that lies in the mountains on
the top.
A fabulous place to
just--nothing to do with Roman
antiquity but just a great place
to wander,
as you can see here,
and every one of the caves,
and there are a lot of them,
have places for wine tasting.
So it's a fun place to go.
Here are the two monuments.
We saw the arch already.
This is the tower tomb.
These are referred to by the
locals as Les Antiques,
Les Antiques;
the arch--the antiquities--the
arch and the tower tomb.
And the fact that they are in
close proximity;
I mentioned the arch may well
have been a city gate.
The Romans always buried their
dead outside the city gate.
City gate, cemetery right
outside.
Extremely well preserved.
Tower tomb, tower tomb because
it's taller than it is wide.
This area of France is
particularly famous because of
Vincent van Gogh,
one again.
Van Gogh spent his last years
in an insane asylum,
as many of you may know,
in St.
Rêmy.
This insane asylum--which you
can see;
this is a Van Gogh painting of
that asylum in which he spent
those last days--is located
exactly across the street from
Les Antiques.
So if you make the pilgrimage
there,
I hope you'll make the
pilgrimage not only to see Van
Gogh,
but I hope that you're
aficionados now of--
in fact, I hope that you go to
see Les Antiques and then
also go to see the asylum of Van
Gogh.
Here's the monument of the
Julii, a tower tomb that was put
up in St.
Rêmy in 30 to 20 B.C.,
so the cusp,
the late-Caesarian into the
Augustan period.
And we think the Julii
represented here are in fact
veterans of Julius Caesar's
army, who have taken his name.
Julius Caesar,
all of his great military
exploits in Gaul,
referred to here by his
veterans who have taken his name
and have settled here on land
that they were given in reward
for their good work.
Again it's a tower tomb;
taller than it is wide;
a stepped base;
a socle with sculptural figural
frieze;
a quadrifrons up here;
Corinthian columns;
and then at the very apex a
tholos that has two
statues inside that
tholos.
This is pretty much the
best-preserved Roman tomb that
we have.
Everything is intact here.
We believe--remember I
mentioned way at the beginning
that we think that a lot of
these Roman ideas came to the
south of France via North Italy,
and we think this was indeed
the case.
In North Italy we know they put
up a lot of these tower tombs,
and we think it's likely that
this sort of thing imitates some
of those tower tombs in the
north of Italy.
I show you a detail of two of
the figural friezes from the
socle of the monument,
which you can see represent
battle scenes.
And you can also see those deep
outlines,
just as we saw at the Orange
Arch, which once again suggest
to us that these artists are
looking at drawings of this kind
of thing that come from the
Greco-Roman world,
and they are copying what they
see.
I don't have time to go into it
here,
but if you look with care at
some of these,
when you're studying this
monument,
you will see that there are
some figures--
while for the most part it
makes sense--
there are some figures in this
crowded scene that don't work.
For example,
here's a figure on the ground,
with a shield above his head,
trying to protect himself
obviously from a combatant.
But there is no combatant there.
And that seems to underscore
again that they are using copy
books, that they are looking at
these things.
They're copying what they like.
They're copying the scene for
the most part,
throwing in some other figures
that they like,
that don't--sometimes don't
even make any sense.
A detail up here of the
tholos,
with the two statues.
I spent about six weeks at this
monument at one point,
in that area at St.
Rêmy, in a little place
near Les Antiques.
And I remember when I was there
that there was this wonderful
headline in the local newspaper
that said--
there was a huge storm,
with lightening and so on,
and the next morning there was
a headline that said "Has
Gaius Lost His
Head?" Because the
locals want to believe that this
is a monument,
not of local army veterans,
but of the Augustan family,
and that the two figures at the
uppermost part were Gaius and
Lucius Caesar.
Well they were not Gaius and
Lucius Caesar,
they were local veterans.
But nonetheless the myth has
continued on.
I want to show you lastly,
for just the minute or so that
remains,
to try to underscore that
point, that the north of Italy
may have been a source for this
kind of tower tomb that we see
at St.
Rêmy, just by showing you
one example.
It's by no means exactly the
same, but it's the best that I
can do, because most of these
tower tombs no longer survive.
But it is a tholos tomb
from Aquileia,
in the north of Italy that
dates to the early Augustan
period.
And you can see that it has a
large base,
with a figural sculptural
decoration here--
this Isles of the Blessed kind
of imagery--
with a tholos at the top
that includes a statue,
and then a pyramidal roof with
a decorative element at the
uppermost part,
and then, as you can see,
some lion statues out in front
to guard that tomb.
It's by no means the same thing
as what I've shown you,
but it gives you an idea that
these kind of tholos
tombs,
on decorated bases,
were popular in the north of
Italy,
and the idea may have made its
way to the south of France via
these north Italian examples.
And lastly, just one last
monument,
because we've tended to be
looking at tombs in isolation,
individual tombs,
rather than tomb complexes,
because it's the individual
tombs and not the complexes
themselves that are well
preserved.
But I want to show you one
excellent example from the north
of Italy,
again from this wonderful town
called Aquileia:
an early Augustan set of altar
tombs that are still preserved
in the actual original burial
plots,
which gives you a very good
idea of what one of these plots
would have looked like.
These are, of course,
not monumental tombs but small
tomb markers in the shapes of
altars,
and then other smaller items,
as you can see very well here.
But it shows you the way in
which the Romans had,
just as one has today,
these burial plots for the
family: these family burial
plots,
that have individual markers of
different family members in
them,
and then has a kind of stone
fence that encircles and
protects their plot.
And you can see that stone
fence down here,
a stone fence that should
immediately remind you of some
of the stone fences that we saw
in Second Style Roman wall
painting,
for example;
that were omnipresent in Second
Style Roman wall painting.
And the last point I'll make
today is just to
underscore--once again,
I think there are lots of
examples of it today;
the tholoi,
for example,
the tholos,
and these fences,
as well as the theatrical
architecture we saw at Orange--
that underscore once again the
close association between
architecture and painting,
from the Republic,
all the way up to the Augustan
age,
and still beyond.
Thank you all.